do you think we'll have a future with
something you call uh afterlife we'll
have avatars that mimic
increasingly better and better our
behavior our appearance all that kind of
stuff
even those are perhaps not no longer
with us
yes i mean
we need
some information about about them
i mean think about my father
i have what he wrote
now he didn't have a word processor
so he didn't actually write that much
and our memories of him aren't perfect
so how do you even know if you've
created
something that's satisfactory now you
could do a rake frederick kurzweil
turing test
he seems like frederick kurzweil to me
but the people who remember him like me
don't have a perfect
memory
is there such a thing as a perfect
memory maybe
the whole point
is for
him to make you feel
a certain way yeah well i think that
would be the goal
and that's the connection we have with
loved ones it's not really based on
very strict definition of truth it's
more about the experiences we share yeah
and they get more through memory
but ultimately they make us smile i
think we we definitely can do that
and that would be very worthwhile
so do you think we'll have a world of
replicants
of copies would there be a bunch of
raker as well
like i could hang out with one i can
download it
for five bucks
and have a best friend ray
and uh you the original cop you wouldn't
even know about it
um
is that do you think that world is
um first of all do you think that world
is feasible and do you think there's
ethical challenges there like how would
you feel about me hanging out with raker
as well and you not knowing about it
doesn't strike
me as a problem
um which would you
the original would you would that
cause a problem for you
no i i
would really very much enjoy it no not
just hang out with me but if somebody
hanging out with you
a replicant of you
well i think i would start it sounds
exciting but then
what if they uh start doing better than
me
and and take take over my friend group
and then and then i'll
because
because they may be um
an imperfect copy
or there may be more social or these
kinds of things and then i become like
the old version that's not not nearly as
exciting
maybe they're a copy of the best version
of me on a good day yeah
but if you hang out with a replicant of
me
and that turned out to be successful i'd
feel proud of that person because it's
based on me
so it's it but it is a kind of
death of this version of you
well not necessarily i mean you can
still be alive right
but
and you would be pro okay so it's like
having kids and you're proud that
they've done even more than you were
able to do yeah exactly
uh it does bring up new issues but
uh it seems like an opportunity
well that that replicant should probably
have the same rights as you do
well that
that gets into a whole issue
[Music]
uh
because when a replicant occurs they're
not necessarily going to have your
rights
and if a replicant occurs to somebody
who's already dead
do they have all the
obligations and that the original person
had did they have all the agreements
that they had
so
i think you're going to have to have
laws that say yes
there has to be if you want to create a
replicant
they have to have all the same rights as
human rights well
you don't know someone could create a
replica and say well it's a replicant
but i didn't bother getting their rights
and so yeah but that would be illegal i
mean
like if you do that you have to do that
in the black market you have to if you
want to get an official replica okay
it's not so easy suppose you created
multiple replicants
uh
the original
rights
uh
maybe for one person and not for a whole
group of per people
sure so
uh so there has to be at least one and
then all the other ones kind of share
the rights
yeah i just don't i don't think that
that's very difficult to conceive for us
humans the the the the idea
that has certain
i mean i've talked to people about this
including my wife who would like to get
back her father
and she doesn't worry about
who has rights to what
she would have somebody that she could
visit with and like give her some
satisfaction uh
and they wouldn't
she wouldn't care about any of these
other rights what does your wife think
about multiple array cores walls
well you had that discussion i wouldn't
address that weather
i think i think ultimately that's an
important question loved ones
how they feel about there's a there's
something about love well that's the key
thing right if the loved one's rejected
it's not gonna work very well so
so the loved ones really are the key to
determinate whether or not this
works or not
but there's also ethical rules
um we have to contend with the idea and
we have to contend with that idea with
ai but what's going to motivate it is
i mean i talk to people who really miss
people who are gone and they would love
to get
something back even if it isn't perfect
and that's what's going to motivate this
and that person
lives on in some form
and the more data we have the more we're
able to reconstruct that person
and allow them to move on right
and eventually as we go forward we're
going to have more and more of this data
because we're going to have
nanobots that are inside our neocortex
so we're going to collect a lot of data
in fact anything that's data is is
always collected
there's something
a little bit sad which is becoming
or maybe it's hopeful
which
is more and more common these days
which when a person passes away you have
their twitter account
you know and you have
the last tweet they tweeted
like something and you can recreate them
now with large language models and so on
i mean you can create somebody that's
just like them and can actually continue
to
communicate i think that's really
exciting because i think
in some sense
like if i were to die today
in some sense i would continue on if i
continued tweeting
i tweet therefore i am
yeah well in some sense i mean that's
one of the advantages of a replicant
that can recreate
the communications of that person
you